hey guys Pete here the Battle of
Winterfell is now over and this will be
a top moments recap video just a quick
one
Game of Thrones Season 8 episode 3 was
one of the most anticipated episodes of
all time and after watching it I believe
it's gonna turn out to be one of the
most divisive episodes of all time as
well so many good theories died on that
battlefield outside Winterfell tonight
when the night king was defeated and his
entire army drop but there will be
plenty of time to get into the details
of the episode when I do my recap and
review later this week for now let's
look at the top moments together and you
can discuss how you feel about the
episode in the comments number 10
Melisandre's returned this was expected
as it felt pretty clear that she had a
role to play in the fight against the
White Walkers she arrived just in time
for the start of the clash and her
lighting the Dothraki weapons ablaze was
definitely one of my favorite moments of
the episode of course things didn't turn
out well for the Dothraki who seemed to
have been wiped out as they attacked the
army of the Dead completely and I do
fear that even though it would have
happened off-screen that we should add
ghosts to the list of casualties here
rip ghosts will never forget number 9
edy saving Sam this whole fighting
sequence was done really well as we see
the chaos of the whites attacking from
what feels like every direction we get
to see dollar said save his knights
watch brother in the nick of time but
unfortunately he pays the ultimate price
for it and now his watch has ended
number 8 barracks death Aria found
herself in a dangerous situation being
swarmed by whites inside of Winterfell
even though she proved her fighting
skills outside just before this happened
she found herself in need of rescuing
once she was indoors
berrak and the Hound step up to help her
to safety but barrack is mortally
wounded in the process after he falls
Melisandre tells Arya that the Lord of
Light brought him back for a purpose now
that purpose has been served so no kiss
of life for barrack to give out and he
won't be coming back either this time
well it wasn't the most dramatic death
in the episode I did like that at least
for barrack
in the end he did something purposeful
his death gets arya safely to Melisandre
and that leads to the next moment number
seven Melisandre and Arya meet again
everyone in this room has been an Arya's
list of people she wanted to kill
Melisandre earned a place on it by
taking Andrea way back in season three
and we've anticipated their reunion ever
since in it they refer back to that
episode where Melisandre told Arya that
she would shut many eyes forever
Melisandre says brown eyes green eyes
and blue eyes emphasis on the blue eyes
then she delivers a callback to Arya's
water dancing teacher Syrio Forel she
says what do we say to the god of death
arya says not today and takes off
running number six Lyanna Mormont death
of all the character deaths we expected
to see it was a little hard to decide if
they would go to killing off Lyanna
Mormont or not she's a freaking kid but
that wasn't enough to spare her she went
down fighting and took out a white giant
with her on the way and it was a pretty
sad occasion this was a death that
shocked me the most and probably
delivered the biggest emotional blow
well some of the other characters hurt
more and we're more important and how
they were essential to the story I just
didn't see this one coming
number 5 the whites over taking the
castle walls at the end of the day this
was one of the most well put together
episodes of TV I've ever seen in this
section of the whites were they start to
go through the trench start to get over
the walls start to drop down into the
yard I love the way we saw them come off
the cliff into hardhome it was kind of
just a well-polished chaotic devastating
frightening it was just a horror show
and it had a great impact and it made
you wonder how the hell they were gonna
get out of it number four the night king
raising the whites we had been
anticipating this what happened since
the actor who plays the night king
mentioned that him and Jon were gonna
have a bigger moment than what
happened at hardhome and this time John
was stuck in the middle of it I thought
that is what made this work even though
I didn't really expect John to die it
was a crazy situation that he found
himself in and we'd all been wondering
who might become White's how that might
go and we saw that Edie was turned and
literally on a Mormont was turned and
basically everybody else who fell in the
battle I'm not sure this is the payoff
that fans were looking for as far as
people turning into whites was concerned
but it seems like that's all that
they're gonna get either way the night
King raising his arms once again worked
for me as it did the first time I saw it
and I thought that was a pretty good
moment number three Jorah Mormont's
death I had Jorah high on my list of
people who would probably die in this
episode I'm thinking most other people
did as well so it wasn't shocking but it
was a fitting end for Jorah he got to
die defending his queen since we saw him
outside the wall it was hard to imagine
that there would be a situation where he
would be literally defending his queen
like right in front of her as it all
played out in the show so if Jorah had
to go then I think this was pretty good
and I thought Ian Glenn and Emilia
Clarke both delivered a memorable
performance so rip Jorah
number two is Theon's death obviously
I'm mentioning the deaths because of the
impact they had as we were watching the
show after episode two it started to
feel like Theon wasn't likely to make it
through the battle and I really made
peace with the fact that he would die in
this episode before it even started I
looked at it like hey he had his moment
when he came back he stepped up and now
he's not gonna have much of a chance to
live in this situation he signed up for
protecting bran which puts him right in
a really dangerous spot I don't know how
I feel about the end of his story
related to the end of this episode but I
really liked that bran told him that he
was a good man I really like that he got
that moment and then he still charged
the night king even though it wasn't
gonna make a bit of difference and he
pretty much knew that going
into it so rip theon greyjoy you're a
good man and number one is the stare
down between bran and the night king of
course this leads into Arya stabbing the
night king and effectively wiping out
the White Walkers which is like I said
going to be probably the most divisive
thing that we've seen in this TV series
history I didn't follow along on Twitter
or do any of that kind of stuff but I
did see some comments and but yeah I
have a feeling that people won't like
the fact that Arya is the one who did
this and probably they won't like that
it happened in episode 3 at all in spite
of all of that I still think that bran
and the night king having their stare
down was an awesome moment I think it
was fantastic and that's where the list
will end and I have to watch it again
what I can say for sure right now is
that it was fantastic looking it was a
great looking episode it definitely was
a twist compared to what most people
said other things that were really good
here was the sound and the music some of
it seemed incredibly dark and hard to
see some of it seemed really chaotic and
it was hard to figure out what was going
on I have to watch again
to see how that plays out on the second
viewing I'm in that spot in that space
that you get into when you really think
you have an idea and you have theories
that you like and they all turn out to
be wrong I mean I wrote 2,000 words or
so yesterday on a video that I ended up
not doing and it was about what comes
after this and the reason I didn't
finish it was because it just was so
hard to imagine that the night King
would die you know my arguments were all
leaning towards him staying in and the
end the video was gonna have a really
short shelf life if it turned out this
way but yeah I don't know what they have
in store in the back end I looked at the
trailer we see that the dragons are both
still alive and they're definitely
making Cersei the big bad as far as we
can tell I don't hate that idea but this
does feel abrupt I'm really just
mourning theories right
now I hope that there's a good reason
that it had to be this way I'm not like
reactionary to the point of like this is
the end that was it they couldn't they
can't redeem themselves from this
because it was a fantastic-looking
episode that especially the Melisandre
stuff and the battle itself but I mean
it looks like we lost ghosts off so he
just charged into the battle by himself
and that's the last we'll ever see of
them I don't see that being popular in
that writing about Cersei being the big
bad I thought to myself they have to top
this that's the real problem is that
they have to talk what has been billed
as what we expected to be the final
showdown the big ending of the White
Walkers so if they have that in their
back pocket and they're able to do that
then I'm on board with it but it's not
what we were expecting let's face it I
don't see Arya being the person who
killed the night king being popular and
that's for a few reasons but really it's
just doesn't it just didn't seem what
was telegraphed I mean I talked to a
friend of mine who's a big fan but maybe
not as deep into the theory side of
things and he actually made a pretty
good point of why he thought it might be
Arya based on stuff that they've shown
us for instance her besting Brienne
whenever they were sparring in the yard
and you know she did do all of the
training necessary to be a skilled
warrior at this point but it just didn't
really seem like that was the way it was
gonna go but overall with the Arya stuff
I think we could go back and say there
was foreshadowing like we could piece it
together but it really wasn't I don't
think anybody thought that this was
gonna turn out this way so it's gonna be
divisive that's just the only thing
there is to say about it but that is
where I line things I don't want to
drone on I have a trailer breakdown to
do and then I want to re-watch and
really get into it and see how I feel on
the second watch and the third watch
I'll be interested to hear what you guys
thought of the episode and what moments
you really thought stood out so leave
that in the comments please like the
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel to follow along I will be
doing the trailer breakdown next and
then I will do a full recap and review
thanks for watching guys I will talk to
you soon